[Music]
Indian doctors are reportedly very
curious over the Curious Case of this
very curious girl who has these curious
hands and I'm curious there we go
what's up with his hands so these hands
she obtained after having a double hand
transplant oh she got both her hands
turning into other people's hands were
they man hands actually work oh oh that
was she a child well she was 16
did she already have man hands kinda in
a way I want opposite color I'm hoping
okay damn if I was a white girl I want
black hands if I was an albino if I was
a black dude I want albino hands just to
[ __ ] it up with the contrast yeah well
you know what's crazy I'm glad you
brought up colors no copy real because
this chick um okay so she actually lost
her hands in a freak road accident back
in 2016 she's currently 21 so what's the
math whatever that math is is how old
she was when she did it she lost her
hands and understand where her hands
what an unlucky placement and it's on
the road yeah so the doctors had no
choice but to amputate both her hands
and forearms oh my goodness and so she
just got the hands up here know she
could wear a polo shirt is it the
hearing since I brought that up so the
doctors are really perplexed because
getting a life like that for biggie I
can [ __ ] I could die right now that
means I would love it so cute okay so
she ended up getting double transplant
right this was from a a male to who had
a darker skin tone than she did
but now the crazy thing is that the skin
tone of the transplanted hands are
getting light dirty
oh so it's matching her skin cells are
getting gentrified
the bone structure like it's not as
needy as they want to work and like
she's getting more feminine wrists so
they're like whoa this holy [ __ ] guys
come on don't you know how that works
the pigment starts to flow in and out
holy [ __ ] those are good transplants
yeah that reminds me of Tina Fey's book
Bossypants where she's like I mean you
know I guess they're more feminine now
but they started did they start as like
Hulk Hogan's arms oh here oh oh holy
[ __ ] that's not I wonder how much more
how did they think this was gonna be a
good idea that in the first place
anybody look this is all guys like yeah
there we go
it was because there was a long list of
people waiting like on the waiting list
for hand transplant but this is not a
common thing especially in India because
a lot of family members don't want to
remove the body yeah yeah and you have
to switch it pretty quickly so there has
to be a freshly dead guy were the
forearms exactly and that's what
happened and she got so lucky because
this the guy that she ended up getting
it from like she just so happened to be
a match and he might have just been
really really tan and now his hands
weren't off he doesn't know what he
injures though there's an India like
like but she's in India - she's pretty
light-skinned - yeah and that was like
guys that's a dark man that was a dark
man mm-hmm
yeah so the guy that she got the arms
from where he was declared brain dead
after a motorcycle accident still those
he's really good because it was in I
actually heard something very
inappropriate and I knew that's not what
you said so I'm like you need a repeat
in your dildo I did waiting dildo daddy
dildo a dildo in India that's illegal
that's on your hands off
maybe so excited by it - she was like
did he build oh yeah that can't be it I
got it thank you thank you so much
anyway so yeah it's crazy though because
when they were doing the transplant this
chick it took 13 hours it involved 20
virgins and 16 anesthesiologists they're
like a team of anesthesia 16 yeah and
then so first they attach the bones and
then the arteries and the veins and then
the muscle tendons and then finally the
skin and luckily was a success because
usually you know with transplants and
stuff that the body can reject it but
luckily was a success okay so she's
masses are Brady turn does it feel like
maybe she's moving up with someone have
nerves Bowman did she even feel it but
nobody it's a man's hand
no like feeling with her with the hands
with the new hands it feels like a new
hand touching swarmy Nikki no just he's
a science thing he doesn't even like
being yourself so it's really not
morning
well she does well when you rub with
your frequently no Nikki you say that
you switch hands just to everyone else
is doing that's why I understand why her
brain wins but then I win so much with
my left no not my right feels like a
stranger yeah and soon her own tongues
gonna tell a stranger it does I can't
get down there look like before her
transplant okay and that's crazy
luckily it's a success but I guess the
crazy part is the fact that the hands
are like now her pigmentation well maybe
he just like went out in the Sun a lot
and now she's thinking doors and that's
what yeah that's really he was really
tan with that so tan holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah but that it looks like he had a
naturally darker complexion but maybe he
worked a job like outside but even the
bone structure and everything to like
how its conforming to her DNA yeah look
at his [ __ ] pinkies compared to her
ping you know the body is so while it is
a scientist they gotta be able to figure
this out because I mean like when I get
a zit in our pop it at hyper pigments
and then it levels out so why is that
mr. science man your skin though not
some other dudes pimple on your face
what if it was someone that dudes pimple
on her face and then she pops it and
then it happens to change into her face
yeah into that into that [ __ ] yeah
transplanting pimples what if it went
the other way his colors start taking
over and then her started turning
his face what's his name [ __ ] what's
that [ __ ] spider-man thing mmm no
don't don't
sim be up sim be it [ __ ] English
venoms you oh yeah that would be nuts
especially from the hands it's like
dominoes I would understand it was like
a head transplant
well they've tried them you've tried
there's a head transplant who
technically owns the owns this person we
don't know yet person is blind now the
head or the body brain runs it yeah
right
no we know of how would it be successful
how do you keep a person alive during a
head keep a brain alive but they don't
know how to find how to connect all the
[ __ ] to a body that's sad are their
brains that are soul I feel like just
let me guys Ramos [ __ ] really a real
allegedly allegedly Walt Disney's his
small no he's not he's frozen luckily
but he's not he's still on he's actually
dead [ __ ] if he really frozen yeah no
he's not he's not I never actually
bothered to see like is this a real fat
huh but it's fun just like the Tupac is
still alive no too much real too much
actually life yeah it's not a conspiracy
that's wrong yeah
and I'll also Elvis to another icon what
yeah yeah well no I don't know about all
this I think he was killed for music
rights you really do
what about Angie absolutely and Prince
and Whitney and Prince and Prince yeah
yeah and Selena that me I don't think so
but everybody else kill for music rights
and Tupac still alive yeah Amy Winehouse
yeah Amy - she just like to have a good
time I think she'd like to drink a lot
yeah they'd raped her and read
illuminati science that she was taken oh
really
what was your favorite color red though
that could be a critical flaw of black
pop smoke pox month maybe I don't know I
don't know his whole thing was really
sketchy okay
well his friends put up the headdress
well did you guys hear that he posts the
night before he was killed he posted an
Instagram he was like showing all of his
bags and cars and all of his like riches
basically and he happened to pan over to
a pock box that had the address of where
he was and he was killed that night what
do you guys want what do you guys think
about the theory that Kid Rock died and
that he was replaced by some white trash
absolutely because he never made good
music never make good music yeah the
body babies over one-hit wonder
absolutely not that man was talent was
[ __ ] magnum opus absolutely yeah and
after that he got replaced by a guy yeah
his name was his name is Peter Carter
yep basically the moonlight sonata'
big movies a buddy we all know that that
we handsome brother speaking in tongues
right yeah they were killed I would a
bomb they were all killed all mobs actor
Dada boo don't eyeball with the bang
bang boogie say up jump the boogie yeah
thank you and also Fred Durst was killed
of Limp Bizkit Eminem ended that career
yeah that was good look at it yeah but
and I didn't know that he was ending the
career of somebody who was actually not
Fred Durst wait did it produce content
cop the limp Biskit back in the day he
rectum here are can be demolished he
said that the Christina Aguilera sucked
on his dick and that ruined his career
obviously why did it ruin well that
would be horrible to if everyone knew
that Chris yeah that would be amazing
imagine they're putting the whole thing
and just oh like I feel like I get it
but I think you've really thought doing
runs with a dick in her throat yeah
absolutely I'd be like keep on running
[ __ ] for example let me imagine like at
the end for that time you turned my
mid-90s imagine like a rumor coming out
that Britney Spears suck your dick your
careers over
oh no no before head shaved that's a
boost truth no we're talking about oops
I did it again Britney she gave you VD
again it comes out that she sucked your
dick during that time your career is
over
no you guys are crazy listen to yo she's
just too hot like how could you have
such a hot ass no I don't get it
we'll never will never agree mm-hmm but
ya rollin rollin rollin woman [ __ ] you
you can't come up with that [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]